Welcome, everyone,
to today's webinar.
We're going to talk about
reproducible examples
from a conceptual point
of view and why they're
surprisingly important,
and then also a great deal
from a mechanical
point of view how
to make your reproducible
examples in a way
that they're easy to
share with other people.
So this short link, the
rstd.io/reprex currently points
to a copy of these
slides on Speaker Deck.
Another very relevant URL
is reprex.tidyverse.com,
which is the website
for the package I'm
going to talk about.
And we may change what
the upper short link links
to as a result of this
webinar because we're
pretty excited to get some
of these materials captured,
but I promise it will
always point to something
very relevant to this
package that will link
to absolutely everything else.
And you're also going
to see that short link
many, many times during
this presentation.
And as said in the
intro, this video
will also be posted within 48
hours, and all of these things
will be publicized.
And this is my license.
So the first thing I want
to do is show basic usage.
And we're just going
to get right into it,
and then we'll unpack
what you just saw.
So I'm actually going
to leave my slides
and go over to RStudio.
So I'm sitting here in
an R studio session.
It's fresh, and I have
a little bit of code
up here in my source editor.
I'm going to make a
factor x, a factor y.
I'm going to combine them
and get what, to most of us,
is kind of a puzzling
result. So this is just
going to be an example
of a small piece of code
that maybe you want to talk
about on the community site
or share with your
local R expert and ask,
what's going on?
So this is how you
would use reprex
to turn this little
snippet of code
into a reproducible example.
This is the path of
least resistance.
We'll talk about
other methods later.
So I would select a
little piece of code
and copy it to my clipboard.
Then over in the R console
I'm going to type reprex.
And you will see that that
little piece of code is run,
and then basically a beautiful,
attractive version of that
is stored on my clipboard,
and I can preview it here.
So if I were to paste the
contents of my clipboard
right now, you actually
see what's called markdown.
And this is what's necessary to
create the attractive version
of this code.
And why is this helpful?
Because you can go to places
like GitHub, the R studio
community site,
or Stack Overflow
and paste this markdown in.
So I'm going to show
you what this would
look like in a GitHub issue.
So that's that same
markdown that you just saw.
GitHub lets you preview
things, and you'll
see that it looks just the
way it did locally for me.
It's been rendered.
It's syntax highlighted.
We have a tiny
little ad down here
that tells people
how you did this.
And I could submit
that as a GitHub issue.
So that is the basic process.
And the reason I
can just type reprex
is that I always have
this package attached.
And so you might
need to call this,
and we're going to talk a
great deal about that next.
So that is what basic
reprex usage looks like.
It creates a small
little piece of code,
renders it nicely, and
it's ready to paste
into other formats.
So this is just a static
version of what we just did.
And this is the GIF that I
use on the reprex website.
I rewatched this clip.
It's from a movie
called Jerry Maguire.
It's still highly recommended.
And basically the reason for
bothering to do all of this
is if you're going somewhere
to have a conversation about R,
to have questions answered, or
to describe a bug in software,
being careful about how you make
your reproducible example makes
it much, much, much easier
for other people to help you.
And I want to explain where
this word came from, reprex.
So Romain first
tweeted this, and I
thought it was just
a great made-up word.
So it is short for
reproducible example.
So it is a completely made-up
word, but it's just very handy.
And I'm going to use the word
reprex over and over and over
again in this webinar, so I
want to be very clear that I'm
using it in, I'd say, three
distinct but related ways.
So I think people, at least
in the small R community,
are starting to say
reprex just as a noun,
like it is a
reproducible example.
And that has nothing
to do with whether you
use this package or not.
But then today's
webinar is going
to show you use of a package
with that same name, reprex,
that you can install from CRAN.
I'll show you how to do
that in just a moment.
And then this is a
pretty small package.
It has a couple functions, that
really the main function it has
is also called reprex.
So this webinar is
going to talk about how
to use the reprex function
inside the reprex package
to produce a good-looking
reproducible example.
And when does this
come up in your life?
It's very handy
for conversations
that you have on
community.rstudio.com.
It's very handy for preparing
questions or answers
for Stack Overflow.
It's very handy for reporting
bugs or making feature requests
for an R package that is
developed on GitHub and also
very useful for having
detailed conversations about R
in Slack or in email.
So a reproducible
example conceptually
is useful in all those places,
and then this package, reprex,
smooths over some
of the mechanics.
So here I want to talk
to you about what you're
going to need to
do on your computer
to make this package
available to yourself.
So reprex does not come with R.
It does not come with RStudio.
You have to make an explicit
effort to install it.
So you should pick
one of these methods,
and it's the type of thing
that you do once per computer.
So you could use
install.packages("reprex")
to install just
the reprex package.
It is also part
of the metapackage
that we call tidyverse.
So if you did
install.packages("tidyverse"),
reprex would be one of the many
packages that get installed
on your machine.
In general, there
is very little harm
that you can do to yourself
by reinstalling packages.
So you also should not
stress out too much about--
you could install just reprex
and then install the tidyverse
and nothing bad will happen.
So do it once per machine
just because that's
the minimum you need to do,
but it's no tragedy if you
reinstall things.
Once you've installed,
you still need
to use our sort of library call
to make the reprex functions
available in your R session.
So you would need to do
this in every R session
that you plan to use reprex in.
So that might be
something that you
do multiple times per day,
certainly way, way, way,
way more than once per computer.
So every time you want
to use the package
you'll need to execute the
library(reprex) command.
Now I use reprex several
times a day for the most part,
and so that would
be very annoying.
So an alternative, if you
also become a semiheavy user
of this package, is to make
it available to yourself
all the time.
So you can control the startup
behavior of R through a file
called .Rprofile.
And, conventionally, it's
found in your home directory.
And so this snippet of
code, suppressMessages
(require(reprex)),
looks a little different
from what you just saw, but
it's sort of a better way
to attach this package
in your startup file.
So you would put this snippet
of code there in your profile.
And then forever more
when you start R,
the reprex package
will be available.
And if you have never thought
about your Rprofile file
before, there is a function in
the usethis package, which you
would also have to install, that
will create it for you if you
don't have it, or
if you do have it,
it would open it
for you for editing
in case you wanted
to put something
like this snippet in there.
So once you've done
those two things--
you've installed it and you've
attached it through either
the library command or
by putting something
in your .Rprofile--
you are ready to use
the reprex function.
And what you saw me do
in that first demo was
I actually called the
reprex function explicitly
in the R console.
And something you'll see
me do before we're done
is we also have put some
what are called RStudio
add-ins into this package
that give you even more
ways to launch this function.
And this is a bit of a sidebar,
but since I have shown you
how to put things in
your Rprofile file,
I also want to tell you
how to do that responsibly.
So reprex is a workflow package.
It's something you would
use in your daily work
to make your life a
little bit easier.
You use it interactively.
I would be pretty shocked to
see it show up in a typical
person's R scripts, R
markdown files, packages,
or Shiny apps .
And so the fact that it doesn't
show up in those things,
it's an interactive
package, makes
it safe to attach
in your R profile.
But I don't want you
to get the wrong idea
and think, oh my God, I should
do this with all my packages.
So I would not want to see
this kind of code using
dplyr or ggplot2 or things that
do show up in your scripts.
And it's because your scripts
would then become highly not
self-contained.
And they would work for
you because of stuff
in your Rprofile, but they
won't work for other people.
So this is an interesting
technique to know about,
but you need to
be really, really
careful about what you do here.
So I think it's safe
to put reprex in there.
It is not safe to
put dplyr in there.
OK, so we're going to
get back to the package
and to reproducible
examples now.
So I wanted to
give a brief intro,
like what on earth in
my life drove me to make
this one of my missions?
Before I joined RStudio,
I was a professor
at the University
of British Columbia,
and I had a course called Stat
454 that has a lot of content
online to this day.
The course continues.
You could go there.
And I ran this course
entirely on GitHub.
And so it meant that all of
my dialogue with students,
both sort of me to
the whole class and me
talking to individual students,
took place in GitHub issues.
And I actually analyzed my
GitHub usage in the course
and I found that
every fall I was
participating in at least 300,
maybe 500 GitHub issue threads.
And that's just in
my teaching life.
So I spend a great deal of time
talking about R in those places
and solving people's R problems.
And to do that well, I actually
wanted to use executable R
code, and the friction involved
in making that look good
started to drive me crazy.
And now that I'm no longer
a full-time faculty member
and I'm working full
time on R packages,
this just gives you a sense
of the intensity of my GitHub
activity over the last year.
So now I still work with tons
and tons of GitHub issues
in a different capacity,
and then I also talk about R
a lot in Slack.
So I still have this
sort of hourly need
to run little pieces
of R code and share
what I'm seeing
with other people.
So trying to remove friction
for myself and other people
lead me to create a few
principles that I knew
had to be true of a tool
to make this easier.
So this is the
reprex philosophy.
I think that
conversations about code
are much more productive if
they contain three things--
well, it's one thing
but three properties--
code that actually
runs; code that I do not
have to run as the reader but
code that I can easily run.
And so there is a little bit
of self-contradiction here,
but the point is you want
to make it easy for people
to interact with your
reproducible example
in a whole bunch
of different ways.
They can just be a consumer.
They can just read
it, or they can easily
grab it and run it themselves,
modify it, and share that back
with you.
So I want to be really
detailed about what I mean when
I say code that actually runs.
So you're going to isolate
a little piece of R code
and you hand it off to reprex.
You've seen one demo.
We're about to do
a whole bunch more.
That code is taken and it is run
in a completely new R session,
and that means it has to be
completely self-contained.
So it must include the command
to load all necessary packages,
and it must create
all necessary objects.
And this can be very
frustrating, for people
but it's extremely important.
So I'm going to go
do this live just
to show exactly what I mean.
So I'm looking at an R script
that contains the code you just
saw in that slide.
And I'm going to restart R.
So let's imagine a typical
interactive R session.
So I'm going to be down
in the console here
and I'm going to
say, oh, I'd like
to play a little
bit with this praise
package I've heard about.
So there I go.
I say library("praise")
done in the console.
Now up in my source
editor I make
a new object called template,
and it's a template string.
Exclamation, your
reprex is adjective.
And so if I then call
the praise function
from the praise package--
I don't expect you to know this.
I'm just using it
as an example--
it's going to create
random little sentences
for us praising someone
for their awesome reprex.
So let's say I want to share
my joy about this with people.
Using the reprex
package, I would select
this little snippet of code.
Again, this is the long way.
I'll show you a short way later.
Copy it.
Go down to the console.
Type reprex and hit Return.
And now let's look
at the preview here.
It shows defining template,
and then my praise call fails.
Error in praise.
Could not find function praise.
And that's because you don't
have the library praise
command here.
So over in that fresh R
session, the praise package
is not available to use.
So here's something
else you might do.
You're like, OK, I'm
going to add that command.
Then I'm going to make
my call to the package.
Let's see if that works.
Copy.
Call reprex again,
and a new error.
Error in grep whatever,
whatever, object
template not found.
So this snippet is incomplete
in a different way.
It actually doesn't
contain the code that
defines the template object.
So here is the full snippet.
It loads the praise package.
It defines the
template object, and it
makes this function call.
So I'm going to copy all
of that to the clipboard,
re-execute reprex, and we
have made an exquisite reprex.
And so that's a
little belabored,
but when I try to answer
R questions for people
and I try to run their code,
the two most common ways
that I fail are that
they haven't explicitly
listed all the
packages they're using
and I have to either
sleuth it out of them
or figure it out for myself
and add those commands,
or the objects they're referring
to are not available to me.
And so those are the two reasons
why I can't run their code.
So on the reprex website I have
a list of dos and don'ts that
are distilled from a lot of
other really fantastic sources
about creating reproducible
examples which are referenced
there.
But the three big,
big high points
are you need to write this
reproducible example using
the smallest, the simplest,
and the most built-in data
set you can get away with.
And that is very
uncomfortable for people.
I'm going to talk
about that in a second.
Include commands on a ruthlessly
strict, need-to-run basis.
And you really need to
strip your example down.
And then I say pack
it in, pack it out,
and don't take liberties with
other people's computers.
And this is referring to making
sure that if you create files,
you remove them, or if you
change the working directory,
you reset it.
If you change options,
you reset them,
but basically leaving
things as you found them.
But I want to talk about--
so let's see, here's
what that web page
would look like if you
want to read it more.
But let me just give a
short example of something
that a lot of people
struggle with which
is that they feel like they
have some big, hairy data object
and they can only show
their example using it.
So tricks to know--
so the read.csv file you
probably think of as normally
being a function that
you use to bring data--
sorry, the read.csv function
is something you usually
bring delimited
data in from a file,
but it also has a
text argument that
allows you to inline
really tiny R objects,
and then also just the
data.frame function itself.
So I'm going to reprex, using
a keyboard shortcut, those two
snippets of code.
And see, that's a very easy way
to make a very tiny data frame
either inline using read.csv or
sort of from first principles
using data.frame.
And then if you are
a tidyverse adherent,
the tibble package
is what takes care
of the care and feeding
of tibbles, which
are a flavor of data frame.
And the tribble
function is extremely
useful for creating tiny little
data frames because it allows
you to write it in this
really humane, row-wise way,
like the same way it would look,
for example, in a CSV file.
So if I reprex this
little snippet,
we'll see very,
very similar output
as what we just saw
with the base function,
but it allows you to inline
the creation, in this case,
of a two-row,
two-column data frame,
or you can, again, use just
the tibble function directly.
And so if you make
a lot of reprexes,
you get really good
at figuring out
how to inline the creation
of very small objects.
Of course figuring out what's
the smallest object that still
shows your problem is
difficult, and we're
going to talk about
that at the very end.
Another principle is that the
reprex should contain code
I do not have to run because
a lot of your readers
have a great deal
of R experience
and sometimes-- not always--
but sometimes they can quickly
see the point without
actually running the code,
but that is greatly enhanced if
they can see the output instead
of having to run it in their
head and in their imagination
and try to figure
out what's happening.
It's just much easier if you
can actually see the output.
So that's why I
think it's important
that your typical
reprex contains the code
and it also reveals the output
being produced by that code.
So here's an example I took
from the GitHub repository
where the readr package
is developed because it's
a perfect little
example, and it probably
was produced with reprex.
You can't tell.
And this person is
just reporting a bug,
but it's like a great
minimal example.
It says if the header in your
CSV contains coded newlines,
you get kind of a weird column
name and you get weird data.
And the fact that this person
provided a small example
and it completely shows
the problem I imagine
is what allowed the
maintainer, Jim Hester,
who's listening to this call,
to quickly label this as a bug.
And we've already got at
least one other user giving it
a thumbs up, meaning they've
experienced it as well.
And so if you would only
have the code here I,
think you'd have a lot less
sort of quick engagement
with this issue.
And so I want to show you--
so code that I can easily
run is very important.
We're going to keep
working with that issue.
So if that person had
instead copied and pasted
the output from
their R console, this
is what we would be faced with.
So if I were Jim Hester and I
needed to reproduce this issue
and make sure that
it's still a problem,
I have a lot of really
annoying editing to do.
So I have to get rid
of all the prompts
at the beginning of the lines.
I have to get rid
of all this output
to isolate the three lines of
code that actually do anything.
So copy, paste
from the R console
hits some of our checklist,
but it's not great
because it's very hard for the
next person to run this code.
Worse than copy, paste
is the screenshot.
So this of course does, again,
hit some of our checklist.
It clearly shows the
code and the output.
But again, if
somebody else wanted
to check this and
reproduce it, they actually
have to retype everything
which, frankly, is never
going to happen.
And so this is what I
want to see in a reprex
because it can be
copy, pasted and run.
So I'm going to prove
that to you right now.
So if I go to this issue
on GitHub and I copy--
I could copy all of this.
As long as I get all
the commands, I'm OK.
So I'm going to put
that on my clipboard.
I'm going to go back to R. Maybe
to make this really explicit,
I'll show you what I copied.
All right, that's what I did.
So I can copy this
again and call reprex,
and I get exactly what this
person was reporting on GitHub.
So I've been able to
reproduce it very quickly
from a copy, paste.
But as you saw, reprex
is like, are you sure
you want to do this because
I've got this output here.
And so if you really want
to get really clean code
from a reprex that
someone else has made,
you capture it and use
one of the undo functions
in the reprex package.
I could use a reprex_clean, and
I'll show you that right now.
So here's what I
copied from GitHub.
So I could copy that
and call reprex_clean.
And now if I paste,
you'll see all the output
has been eliminated.
And so I think that's a
slightly obscure thing
you might want to
do, but there are
the full set of sort of
backwards functions in reprex.
So it helps you take
code that people
have copied from the console
or that they have already
made a reference from.
So we've gotten to, essentially,
the meat of the webinar now.
So if you were really
interested in basic usage,
you've seen it now.
And now I'm going to go into
the shock-and-awe section
where I run through a lot
of more-interesting features
of the reprex package that I
still think are pretty cool.
So the slides show you what
we're about to do live.
So I'm going back
to RStudio, and I'm
in a script called shock and
awe where I'm going to restart R
just for good measure.
So the first thing
I want to show you
is how frictionless
reprex can make it to talk
to people about figures.
So I'm going to load the
Gapminder data and ggplot2,
and I'm going to make
a plot with ggplot2.
So you see it down
here in my plots pane.
So let's say that
there's something
about this I don't
like or that I want
to discuss with a colleague.
I can use reprex for this.
So, as usual, I can select the
snippet, copy to my clipboard,
and run reprex.
You're going to see
all the same stuff.
So we've got a nicely
rendered reprex
that includes the figure.
But watch this.
I'm going to go to a GitHub
repo that I created just
to play around with.
I'm going to create a new issue.
I have a question about this
plot, and I'm going to paste.
And let's look at
what we've got.
We have the usual sort of
nicely formatted markdown.
And look at this.
So when reprex rendered this
code, it made your figure
and pushed it up to Imgur
and dropped this link
into your markdown.
So if I submit this
issue, people see my code
and they see the actual
figure that you just made.
So this is an example of one
of the cool things you can do.
That removes a tremendous
amount of friction
if you're trying to have a
quick conversation with somebody
about code that
produces figures.
So we're going to go back
to this shock-and-awe script
and we're going
to execute reprex
many times, showing some of the
options and different arguments
you have.
So so far I've only shown
you reprexing when the source
code is on the clipboard, but
there are a lot of other ways
to provide the input.
So you can provide it
directly in the reprex call
as an expression.
So here you see that the
assignment of x and y
gets done, and we compute
the correlation between them.
There's also an input argument,
that I'm actually not going
to demonstrate, where you can
provide the source as a file
or as a character vector.
reprex by default
goes and does its work
in the session temp directory.
That's all part of it
sandboxing all of your work.
But if your reprex does, for
example, file input and output,
it could be much
easier to force reprex
to work in your current
working directory.
So outfile = NA is
shorthand for that.
So if I ask R to write the first
six letters of the alphabet
to a file with outfile
= NA, of a sudden
these four files that
reprex needs to create
are being left behind
in my working directory
instead of in a temp directory.
And it's the R script
that reprex makes,
it's the HTML that it
uses for the preview,
and the markdown that it puts
on the clipboard for you.
So all those usual
files are left behind
in a much more accessible place.
But you'll notice it has a
godawful filename because we
just created it out of thin air.
So if you want to work
somewhere specifically
and have nice filenames, you
could also provide the base
for that in outFile.
And now you see that
it leaves the same four
files behind but they have
a much better filename.
So so far I've been
producing reprex output
that's optimized for GitHub.
So it's producing what's called
GitHub flavored markdown.
But Stack Overflow is
another common target,
and that produces slightly
different-looking markdown.
Stack Overflow doesn't
use fenced code blocks.
It uses indented code blocks.
And let me show you what
this would look like.
I'm going to pretend
like I'm going
to answer my own question
on Stack Overflow,
but I won't actually
submit this.
But now if you paste
that into Stack Overflow,
it also has a preview
feature, and it
will be formatted correctly
for Stack Overflow.
You can also make
reprex produce--
it creates that R script,
which seems sort of weird,
but an R script that includes
the output as comments.
And that is very handy
for pasting into an email
or into Slack.
So I'm going to show you
the Slack version of that.
So this is me talking
to myself on Slack.
I'm going to create
a code snippet.
Paste it.
Maybe I always have it set
to R. You create a snippet.
And that would create a
little R file in Slack
properly syntax highlighted.
And again, people could copy,
paste it into R and run it,
or sometimes you just
want to inline it.
You don't get the
syntax highlighting,
but that also looks quite nice.
The final venue I'll talk about
is RTF for rich text format.
And this is a very
experimental venue.
It only works
probably on the Mac
at this point because
I actually have to call
an external utility to do this.
But I'd like to show you
this, and in fact it's
how I made the
slides for this talk.
So we run a little
bit of code, but now I
can go over to Keynote or
PowerPoint or something,
and I could paste that in.
I'm getting rendered R code that
is properly syntax highlighted.
And that is, in fact, how all
the snippets in my webinar
were produced.
You can suppress the
inclusion of that little ad
at the bottom, or
you can include it.
You can ask for your reprex
to include session info.
And for the GitHub venue, it can
be placed in this cute little
collapsible thing.
So this is a great
thing to include
if you think, for example,
that the bug you're recording
could possibly be related
to the version of software
on your computer.
And I love that it
gets folded here.
So sometimes people include
this when they don't need to,
and it's kind of overwhelming.
So the fact that we can
put it in this folding tag
is really nice.
reprex can also use the styler
package to restyle your code.
So here's a really, I would say,
poorly formatted piece of code.
So by default, reprex
trusts that you
know what you're hearing and
that you like your formatting.
But if you don't
trust yourself, you
can explicitly ask for
reprex to restyle your code
and give it a much more
conventional layout.
You can be silly and
change your comment string
and make it some sort
of emoticon if you want.
reprex is part of the tidyverse,
so the tidyverse metapackage
can be quite chatty at
start up and tell you
all the packages that
you've just attached
and if there are
conflicts between them.
So we actually have a special
argument where you can control
whether you want that or
not, and usually you don't.
So we default to silencing it.
And then the last
thing I'll show
you is reprex can actually
capture input that,
in an interactive session,
shows up in your console
but it's actually being
sent to standard output
or standard error.
So I'm going to install
a package from GitHub
that requires compilation.
This takes a moment, so
I'm going to chat over it.
But what you're going to see
when this reprex actually
renders is that we have captured
everything that would normally
show up in the R
console when doing this,
so the stuff that is
sort of coming from R
as well as the
things that are being
sent standard output
and standard input.
I was hoping that
would be enough time.
There we go.
And so here's the output of
installing the bench package
from GitHub, which does
require compilation.
So this is the part that's
coming through sort of normal R
channels, and this
is capturing what's
being sent to standard
output and standard input.
So that was a very quick live
demo of some of the more--
I don't know if they're
really advanced,
but features you don't
need in every reprex
but that you might
need before long.
A lot of the things that I
showed you toggling on and off,
you can actually set up your
own personal defaults for these
things by, again, putting
some code in your .Rprofile,
which we've already
talked about.
So this is just an example
of someone who hates the ad.
They always want to
include session info.
restyle their code.
They have a whimsical sense of
what the comment string should
be for output, and
they always want
to see the tidyverse
startup message.
So these are not my
defaults, but it's
an example of what you can do.
And the last thing I'll
show you mechanically
is most of the time I do
not do what I've shown you,
which is copying
code to the keyboard
and then going to the
console and typing reprex.
There are two RStudio
add-ins that really
accelerate your reprex life.
One of them is called Render
reprex, which launches a GUI--
I'll show you that in a second--
or reprex selection
literally reprexes the code
that you have selected, and it's
absolutely conceived for use
with a keyboard shortcut.
And RStudio lets you modify
your keyboard shortcuts.
And so I have bound that
add-in to Shift-Command-R. This
is how I'd usually use reprex.
And, for example, Hadley
also uses it a lot.
He has bound it
to something else.
And let me go show
you the add-in.
So again, I could select
the snippet of code
that made that figure
and launch the add-in.
And so this allows me to
specify a lot of the things
that you can specify in
the call by clicking.
So I am going to take the source
from the current selection.
Let's target Stack Overflow.
And yes, let's append
the session info.
Quick Render, and
the usual things
happen, and the usual
output appears down here.
And Stack Overflow doesn't
have the capability
to support this
little folding toggle,
so the session info actually
gets dumped in there
in its full glory.
So these are two other
ways to get your input
into the reprex function
that actually are probably
more humane than typing
it in all the time.
All right, the last
thing I will say--
I'll try to go quite quickly
because we're already
at 45 minutes--
is talking a little bit about
the human side of making
reproducible examples.
And now this has nothing to
do with the reprex package.
It's just about asking questions
so they actually get answered.
And I like this image because
it conveys somehow that we're
talking about programming.
Maybe we're all supposed
to be acting like robots.
And people often seem to assume
that they're talking to robots,
but there's a lot of humans
involved in this process.
And I want to warn you,
I'm giving a little bit
of tough love here.
There's been a lot of, although
probably still not enough, talk
of experts being empathetic to
newcomers and question askers.
But since this is
a talk targeted
at people asking questions
and comparing examples,
I also want to say it has to
go the other direction as well.
So bear with me for a moment
here, but I need to say,
with all the love in
the world, sometimes
people come with a
question and they
have a very rigid theory
about what's wrong
or how they should
be solving a problem.
But if your theory about what
was going wrong was so great,
you wouldn't be here asking
this question right now.
And this is the origin
of why people really
want to see code instead
of having sort of a prose
discussion because it's
very hard sometimes
to tell what people are
really talking about.
The other life phenomenon
I want to link this to is--
I don't know if you've
had this experience,
but if you've ever
tried to help,
for example, one of your
relatives sort out a computer
problem over the phone, it
can be extremely difficult.
A lot of what they're saying
doesn't really make sense.
They don't use the words you're
used to to refer to things.
You just feel like you can't
really get a grip on things.
And this is basically
what it feels
like when you're trying to
answer someone's programming
question just based
on English prose.
And again, this is
why people constantly
push you to actually just
show a small piece of code.
It removes all
sorts of ambiguity.
So let's assume that
everybody, the question
asker and the question answerer,
is acting in good faith.
And if they're not, then
they're irrelevant to me.
So everyone's in good faith.
It turns out that experts
posting on public sites
actually are afraid to post
code that doesn't work.
And so another reason why these
people want to see your code
is they're not just
reading it and guessing.
Most of these people are
actually running your code,
proving that their
proposed solution works,
and then they post it when they
know that it's safe to do so.
And this was a big
revelation to me.
I really used to think that
the people I looked up to
as experts just knew
all this stuff by heart
and they were answering
all these questions just
off the cuff.
And then it gradually
dawned on me
that part of why they're
experts or expert behavior
is that they are constantly
running lots of small examples
and experiments.
So sharing your problem in
code is extremely fruitful.
Making a good reprex
is a lot of work.
Sometimes you think I can only
show my problem in my R session
and I haven't restarted
R for seven months
and it requires the full
data set from my thesis.
And that is, in fact, true.
It is a lot of work, but
you're asking other people
to solve a problem,
and so this is
part of meeting them halfway.
But it turns out you get
a lot out of this as well.
So let's be very selfish.
If you make a good reprex out
of your hairy, messy problem
and if you reproduce other
people's problems-- even
reproducing other people's
problems is a real service,
and then sometimes you're
going to be able to solve them.
It turns out this
discipline, it's
like playing scales or
serving over and over again.
You actually get better at
programming by doing this.
And the last selfish
point that I'll make
is it turns out when you sit
down to make a good reprex out
of your problem and you
keep it self-contained,
you strip down your giant hairy
data set to the smallest data
set that reproduces the
problem, it is amazing
how often you end up
answering your own question
in the privacy of
your own home and you
didn't have to make yourself
vulnerable to other people.
So this is a great
revelation, and I
think the reason this works is
that when you have a problem
it's very easy to just
keep going in circles
and banging your head
against the desk,
but there's something about
preparing it for other people--
and the reprex package is also
being a real hardass about
making sure that your
problem is self-contained--
it kind of knocks you out of
that very unproductive place
and gets you back on the path
of actually working the problem.
So most people report
this when they first
start making
reproducible examples
is that it's kind of amazing
how often this exercise means
you actually answer
your own question.
I will skip over this section
since we're out of time
and I didn't think
people wanted to know it,
but it's here, a
little bit about what's
happening behind the scenes.
And I will conclude.
I want to give a huge
thank you Yihui Xie
and all the people who have
brought us the rmarkdown
package and Pandoc.
The reprex package is just a
wrapper around those things,
and I mean that in
both senses, like that
is literally all that it is.
So in some sense there's
not much there there.
But on the other hand
when I first made
it and especially now that
I've worked on it more,
there's actually a
lot more going on.
The friction that it
removes is friction
that is really important
to remove, I think.
So in any case, it could not
be possible without rmarkdown
and Pandoc.
And, in fact, I should thank
all the coauthors of reprex,
and there's a lot of people
who have contributed to it
and a lot of users who
have been extremely
generous with their bug
reports and feature requests
and reporting how things
work on different platforms.
So to conclude, go
forth and engage
in very precise code-heavy
conversations about R.
I'm going to take a look
at the questions now.
Can reprex be able
to also capture
variables in the
environment and include
in the reproducible example?
Currently it cannot, and that
is very intentional because we
really prioritize
the sandboxing.
I am actually contemplating
basically creating a backdoor
for this mostly because
of creating RTF snippets,
but at the moment it cannot,
and that is intentional.
But I'm open to people
sharing their use
case about why that should be.
But basically if you do this--
yeah, there are
ways you can do it
that actually make those objects
available to other people
as well, but it becomes a
much heavier-weight package,
so so far we have not done that.
Often times-- this
is a continuation
of that question--
the issue is buried
in some part of larger code.
And rather than going
back to the places
where that data is
gathering or calculated,
wouldn't it be nice to grab the
variable in the current state?
Again, like yes and no.
I would say extracting that out
is perhaps part of your job.
Well, I'm now realizing
that some of these questions
have been answered.
Does reprex, the
function, actually
check that the code
is self-contained
or does it just
generate the template?
It just generates a template.
So the way you would find
out that your code is not
self-contained is
that you get an error.
But it explicitly allows
errors because sometimes you're
using reprex to show errors.
So no, it's on you, the
human, to decide if you're
getting the result you expect.
Does readr::read_csv support the
text argument as an alternative
to file or is that
only in read.csv?
readr also does this.
It also supports the inline
creation of a data frame.
It does it through
its primary argument.
So you would want to read
the help for read_csv,
underscores but in fact
it's actually sort of even
a smaller departure
from your usual use.
I think I have another instance
of the same question, which
is could reprex help you
package up an existing data set
and stick it into your data?
That reprex dos and don't
document outlines various ways
of doing this.
For example, dput
is a great function.
If you have a slightly awkward
object and you simply cannot
make your point
without using it,
dput at least creates a
representation of that that you
can put into a reprex.
But so far, you're right.
I have not made this terribly
easy, and at least the story
I tell myself is that finding
a really simple object
is intrinsically part
of the reprex task.
But this does come up
over and over again.
Can you do a reprex
for a Shiny app?
It's not easy.
I think the Shiny team is or
has developed their own web
page talking about how
you create Shiny reprexes,
and they don't use this package.
So now I'm talking about
reprexes as a concept.
Let's see, can reprex
produce interactive plots?
All I will say is
I have not done so.
So I'll end on this question.
I don't know.
It would have to be tried.
But what I will
say, the slide that
I skipped over, what
actually happens--
so currently reprex works
by dumping your R code
into a templated R script.
And I have contemplated
revisiting this and dumping it
into an and rmarkdown
file, and then it
would be much more capable
in terms of what you can do.
In some ways there's a lot of
equivalence between rendering
R scripts and rmarkdown
files, but there
are some key differences.
And so I could imagine
that the ability to include
interactivity is probably
present if you're using
rmarkdown and could easily
be absent if you're using .R.
All right, I think
I will leave it
here and conclude the webinar.